okay so remember he's trying to finally
displace see he's not grabbing in there
and just stand them there because you're
you would go
forward forward right you go
forward you guys understand so it's not
a grip you you e to get off the grip and
and you're attacking back okay he's
pushing forward for followup
attacks so as he's going your t cling
that and watch my shoulder in space
plotted in space it's going you see just
right out of his
reach
boom
okay so that he falls into that
void and his shoulder goes forward of
his
hand now you project his on
then and then the arm is vulnerable so
you take the arm pinning the
shoulder this first part is
timing shoulder
down we have to match his
r
so my shoulder can't go straight out to
the
side it's going to do a
circle this
way almost like I would doido
ten
not straight out to the side you're
going to get
caught
Circle boom
project then to keep the
Integrity of the radius you're using
your other hands in this
space boom just keeping them out there
for you to project the grid
yeah
okay I don't want to move in with this
that's going to be y Yang is I trying to
move into this and move him instead his
inertia that was coming forward that
inertia is Yang energy and I ground the
yangong energy go back one little step
and he goes
forward boom that's what I push so he's
going that way and I enter immediately
into that hi
opening I don't need me to make him
go down do you
understand around and pop then I'm
in boom
on not here and then I'm
entering he didn't bounce off of
me
set up the cew projection
boom
create cre your space then
me
sh
you have to see past the shapes of
things okay so uh let's just do the
first one again so he's got that spinal
displacement plot my shoulder in space
and turn and plot my shoulder in my so
space time okay so as he's coming in I
Circle do you see okay and so I'm at the
edge of his power that's there's nothing
on this arm right here as opposed to
stay there stay where he was that's
where his intention was instead of me
being here you're still pushable on
there I can feel that so I
rotate right I rotate to where it's off
now it's off and then I move around it
let him fall into it and then I
project everything happened
here right
there everything that happened after
that was just because I wanted his
balance to go that way so the same thing
he he
goes and I'm taking it off again he's
taking it off cuz he's over
there so he's coming in
boom right where he's grabbing by
shoulders moving you see and he's out
he's not going to go that way he's he's
going to go that
way
no there was too late I'm too
late
right and
but and but don't try try to make him go
that way it's a different pushi angle
the entry is just the
same just
smaller
but you have to free your shoulder in
the other one you could keep that tent
shoulder you see you can keep it and you
move it to zero pressure and you keep it
and you go and it looks like it's the
same but you see it doesn't
project on this one you can't keep that
stiff shoulder you have to loosen the
shoulder has to be
soft soft
and that's hard to do because you know
he's coming and wo and you tense up in
in anticipation of that but you have to
be soft
what
okay not really what I wanted to work on
but uh you're killing me okay it doesn't
matter which version you
do you cannot step you know what you
have to do when your
arms so you cannot step any old place
because your arms are dictating where
your foot can go so that your Center
stays with your arm so if I go over here
you see I'm on the outside I go over
here I'm not my Center is over here so I
have to step in a place where my hands
are on my center line but I have to step
in a way in a rate that I also get the
angle cancellation on his shoulder go
back and then I go around this
hand you see as opposed to into this
hand I don't want to go into the hand a
second time I have to go around the hand
so I go I I have to figure out where
that is it's not a free-for-all it's not
guessing and you can't go got his
shoulder down
no okay okay everything has to be set
up and be and beside the space the
timing is also governed that's what my
is time and space so this kind of looks
like it's going to be all right but if I
leave my hands behind I just did the
same thing the same mistake it goes up
into my
shoulder let's start
again okay
add a particular Vector with a
particular weight rate of rotation and I
have to accomplish shoulder down and get
around here so that's where I go and
then it's easy
peasy bring some Consciousness to that
don't just keep stepping
wherever
don't don't just put your EDB anywhere
you got all that to
accomplish here we
go all right we're just going to get
here you you keep trying to turn this
turn that wrist do do you understand
that
so see how my hand
shape you see that you you need to get
this but you think you do it by turning
the
wrist got it and you're go try your
hardest you're a strong
dude you
see so
instead we'll just go there again grab
and you're in that position okay instead
of trying I'll show you you can do it to
me too okay don't let me turn your
wrist it's not going to happen do you
get it so don't make it happen I'm going
to just show you what I'm going to do
I'm going to go to the other side of
your wrist it turned do you see that do
you see that and then I'll push your
elbow down you can keep your grip if you
want and now it's even out even more
hey do you see
that do you get that
hey
you get that hey okay so watch how I'm
doing that on
him that's one of the things that I
mentioned I have to get around this grip
I don't turn it over and move it
over I go I have to enter again you see
how I seek height at zero
pressure don't try to come in and knock
him
down he's
there you're at zero pressure on your
ENT around it you see around
it around it and you take the elbow
which takes the shoulder and this is
there to catch it catch it there comes
off not there to pull it off not there
to pry it off okay and you have to go
around it in your
EDI